ELECTED TONIGHT AND IT COULD BE
CLOSE, BRET?
>> Bret: ALEXIS, THANK YOU.
>> Martha: LET'S BRING IN A FEW
MORE MEMBERS OF OUR PANEL KARL
ROVE IS WITH US, FORMER WHITE
HOUSE DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF TO
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH AND
KELLYANNE POLLSTER AND FORMER
SENIOR COUNSELOR TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
>> Bret: ALSO WITH US JUAN
WILLIAMS, TREY GOWDY FORMER
CONGRESSMAN OF SOUTH CAROLINA
AND HOST OF "SUNDAY NIGHT IN
AMERICA."
JOSH KRAUSHAAR SENIOR
CORRESPONDENT FOR AXIOS.
ALL RIGHT, KARL, WHAT ARE YOU
LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW.
YOU SEE SOME OF THE RESULTS FROM
FOX NEWS VOTER ANALYSIS AND YOU
HAVE ALL THE KNOWLEDGE YOU HAVE.
>> I'M NOT --
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHAT'S INTERESTING TO ME IS
THIS IS LIKE A CAMPAIGN WITH TWO
DIFFERENT AGENDAS BEING TALKED
ABOUT.
NORMALLY FIGHT OVER BIG THINGS,
THE WAR IN VIETNAM, THE WAR IN
IRAQ.
BUT THIS IS TWO DIFFERENT
ISSUES.
SETS OF ISSUES.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE ECONOMY AND INFLATION.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT CRIME
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
BORDER AND DEMOCRATS ARE TALKING
ABOUT ABORTION, THREATS TO
DEMOCRACY AND CLIMATE.
AND THESE THINGS DON'T
INTERSECT.
AND SO EACH PARTY IS OUT THERE
TALKING TO A DIFFERENT SEGMENT
OF THE ELECTORATE.
PROBLEM FOR THE DEMOCRATS TWO
FOLD.
ONE IS THE REPUBLICAN ISSUES ARE
MORE IMPORTANT TO THE VOTERS.
WE SAW THAT WITH ISSUE OF 451%
THINK THE ECONOMY AND INFLATION
IS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE.
SO, THEIR ISSUE SET IS NOT AS
IMPORTANT.
SECOND OF ALL, PROBLEMATIC FOR
THEM, INDEPENDENTS IN THIS
ELECTION ARE LOOKING MORE LIKE
REPUBLICANS.
THAT IS TO SAY THEIR CONCERNS
ARE MORE LIKE THE REPUBLICAN
CONCERNS THAN THE DEMOCRATIC
CONCERNS.
AND FINALLY, THE INTERESTING
THING TO ME IS ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT DEMOCRATS ARE PUT A LOT OF
EMPHASIS ON IS THREATS TO
DEMOCRACY.
AND, YET, THERE IS A NEW ABC,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" POLL THAT
SHOWED THAT THEIR LEAD ON THIS
ISSUE IS 47-43.
THAT IS TO SAY THEY ARE THOUGHT
BY 47% OF THE PEOPLE TO BE
BETTER ABLE TO HANDLE THAT ISSUE
THAN THE REPUBLICANS WHO GOT 43.
AND WHY?
BECAUSE EACH SIDE HAS ITS OWN
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT THOSE
THREATS TO DEMOCRACY ARE.
SO YOU HAVE CONSERVATIVES AND
REPUBLICANS SAYING, YOU KNOW, A
GOVERNMENT THAT DOESN'T, YOU
KNOW, GIVES AWAY HALF A TRILLION
DOLLARS WITHOUT PASSING A LAW
THROUGH CONGRESS OR ONE PARTY
RULE OR THE POLITICIZATION OF
THE DOJ OR THE FBI, ALL OF THESE
KINDS OF THINGS ARE SEEN BY
PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT AS THREATS
TO DEMOCRACY AS WELL AS THE
JANUARY 6TH ATTACK ON THE
CAPITOL SEEN BY PEOPLE ON THE
LEFT AND RIGHT AS A THREAT AT
THE DEMOCRACY.
>> Martha: KELLYANNE, THAT'S A
GREAT POINT.
THAT'S THE WORLD WE LIVE IN
WHERE EACH SIDE HAS THE ISSUES
THAT THEY ARE MOST FIRED UP
ABOUT AND SEEMS LIKE THEY ARE
LIVING IN TWO SEPARATE COUNTRIES
AT TIMES.
YOU LOOKED AT THE FOX NEWS VOTER
ANALYSIS AS WE GET A GAUGE OF
WHAT SOME PEOPLE'S MINDS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK SO FAR?
>> SO, MARTHA, THIS COUNTRY NO
DOUBT IS DIVIDED.
OUR SENATE IS DIVIDED.
WASHINGTON IS GUIDED.
SOME OF OUR HOUSEHOLDS ARE
DIVIDED BUT THE COUNTRY IS NOT
DIVIDED ON THE BIGGEST ISSUES
THAT ARE MOTIVATING THEM TO THE
POLLS IN THESE MIDTERMS.
OVER 70% OF AMERICANS TELL THE
FOX NEWS POLLSTERS AND OTHER
POLLSTERS THAT THEY ARE VERY OR
EXTREMELY CONCERNED ABOUT CRIME,
ABOUT INFLATION, ABOUT
IMMIGRATION AND BORDER SECURITY.
AND, YET, THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
TAKEN A HUGE GAMBLE ON CREATING
THIS PARALLEL UNIVERSE AND
TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING TOTALLY
DIFFERENT.
WE'LL SEE IF THEIR GAMBLE PAYS
OFF.
THE OTHER THING THAT IS NOT IN
DOUBT THAT YOU ARE DEALING WITH
VERY UNPOPULAR PRESIDENT WHOSE
DISAPPROVAL RATING HAS BEEN OVER
50% FOR A YEAR.
INDEPENDENTS ARE LEANING FAR
MORE TOWARD REPUBLICANS.
WILL THEY SHOW UP?
I THINK FOR INDEPENDENTS THE BIG
QUESTION IN THE MIDTERMS IS NOT
JUST FOR WHOM TO VOTE BUT
WHETHER TO BOTHER AT ALL.
SOME OF THOSE P&A PARTIES
PARTICULARLY DEMOCRATS VOTED
EARLY.
DEMOCRATS WERE ABLE TO BANK
THEIR VOTES EARLY.
THE OTHER THING IS THE
REPUBLICANS THIS TIME HAVE
GAMBLED ON EXPANDING THE
ELECTORATE.
AND NOW THE REPUBLICAN PARTY'S
ELECTORATE, THE VOTERS LOOK A
LOT MORE LIKE AMERICA AND SO DO
THEIR CANDIDATES.
WE WILL SEE IF THAT GAMBLE
ACTUALLY PAYS OFF.
I BELIEVE IT.
WILL THE REPUBLICANS HAVE
INVESTED IN WHAT I CALL THE
NONSEXY STUFF IN POLITICS.
NOT JUST THE BIG TV ADS OR
RALLIES OR THE CANDIDATES.
THEY HAVE TALKED TO VOTERS
1 MILLION VOLUNTEERS.
THE DIGITAL 10 YEARS AGO WHEN
ROMNEY LOST AND DID AN AUTOPSY
IS MUCH BETTER.
ONE THING I'M LOOKING AT TONIGHT
IF IT'S REAL THAT THE SUBURBAN
WOMEN, 20% OF THE ELECTRIC TORE
RAT ARE TRENDING REPUBLICAN.
I THINK MANY ARE NOT VOTING
THEIR GENDER THEY ARE VOTING
THEIR KIDS.
NEVER STILL OUT THERE AS PARENTS
AS A YEAR AFTER GLENN YOUNGKIN
TOOK VIRGINIA AND JACK
CIATTARELLI ALMOST DID.
A LITTLE BIT OF ABORTION.
A LOT OF INFLATION AND CRIME.
BUT SO MUCH EDUCATION IS A
SLEEPER ISSUE IN THIS ELECTI